[Musique]
une autre région de la manque Nord avec
son taux d'humidité
images
vont pourtant
juste la Garonne côté
il fait moins 10
j'ai mis 4 heures à monter
je redescends une minute
trop drôle le soleil
ça en aura valu la peine j'avais de la
neige jusqu'à la taille à la fin de la
rando
juste en train d'admirer le paysage
c'est fou ce qu'on peut faire de nos
jours je vise le plateau là en bas je
tire ma tête en avant et vers le haut
pour accélérer aussi un état des lieux
de des trucs qu'on a pu remarquer qui
sont un peu aberrant en tournée exemple
l'eau il y a maintenant quelques marques
sans faire la pub qui font des
contenants beaucoup plus gros il y a les
fontaines à eau on avait acheté une
fontaine à eau et puis on a un allé en
tournée en les mettait à deux endroits
stratégiques près de la scène et puis
dans les dans les dans les coulisses et
ben c'est beaucoup plus simple avec des
gobelets qui sont jetables et
biodégradables
nickel pour lui faire ma déclaration ma
chérie je t'aime c'est la Saint-Valentin
et ce soir je te le dis je t'aime non je
vais voir le match
[Musique]